um okay
why don't we let's talk to someone else
right i mean why not let's go to the
state of texas and talk to quincy from
texas quincy you're on there oh gosh
damn i didn't expect to get on okay
well anyways i was sort of curious um
you know i have a very difficult time
sort of empathizing with like the
viewpoints of conservatives okay it just
seems like
you know the more you take a more
empirical view on the world the more you
learn about history
you just can't sign off to a lot of
these things that like
conservatives worry about like they
worry about
you know like um like not changing race
policy even though we have like a
history of
basically oppressing races right
like uh i just
i just think that conservative is just
like um conservatism is just like dumb
overall okay
it just doesn't you're
you're losing patience for ignorance and
stupidity it sounds like
uh yeah i just um
i don't know i just feel like it's the
less
less intelligent position
and that like it's not really
set to like
stand the course of time really
well you know here's what i would say to
that without like arguing or debating
the merits of the because this is a very
it's a very surface level argument
conservatives are just dumb
let's skip the argument i think
my response to you would be hey you know
what
um just calling people dumb whether they
are or aren't probably isn't really
going to
achieve the change that we want and so
we need to think of what we can do like
let's say maybe that's true
or maybe they're not dumb but they're
just wrong or whatever right
either way we need to find some way
to
realize and deal with the fact that
these folks are a big part of american
society and we have sought problems to
solve regardless and how can we actually
do it and it's not by just calling them
dumb so i think i would take like a more
pragmatic approach
okay i see what you mean
yeah are you clicking a pen or what is
that noise are you clicking a pen open
and shut uh it's uh it's a butterfly
knife you're opening and closing a knife
okay
yes
all right good well listen i'm gonna let
you go let's continue to think about
this issue i think that there's a lot to
it and uh the only caller i'm aware of
that was doing knife play
during the phone call that we had
let's go
next
to
mike the new dad mike the new dad is on
the air
mike
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
how you doing man good congratulations
on being a new dad
thank you um i just wanted to say i
appreciate you kind of covering the pete
buddha judge thing and
sort of trying to normalize uh paternity
leave for uh for new dads i kind of
thought it was a bit of a joke about um
uh being a new dad and actually being on
it i found it uh quite beneficial um
since my wife kind of wrapped up her
maternity leave and i've had this time
to uh to bond with uh with my daughter
are you do you get paid paternity leave
or you're just allowed to take time off
but unpaid
yeah no it's uh it's paid so uh if you
live in uh or work in the state of new
york um basically how it works is is um
the state will cover 60 percent of your
your pay
um but a new policy like my company had
this year was is they just give you a
hundred percent of your pay and benefits
um while you're out on paternity leave
so it's a total of uh
12 weeks um so it works out to works out
to be three months and you just have to
use it within the first year of uh of
your of your child the date your child's
born so you could take it in two week
increments all at once however you kind
of want to split it up um but
essentially
um
like my company actually i found out is
only
like even though they're giving me 100
of my pay they're only responsible for
40 the remaining 40 percent that was
gonna be my question that was going to
be our question are they just matching
up to that last 40 yeah yeah so they
just match up to the last 40 so i mean
it it it's interesting that more
companies kind of don't do it like if
you work for a bigger business
considering they're they're only on the
hook for the the remaining 40 percent
and i mean i'm not an accountant but i'm
i'm sure there's some way that they're
going to be able to write off some of
that with with me not technically
working um but but yeah
and how much sleep are you getting
[Music]
oh boy
you you just cut out mike unfortunately
it sounded like you were trying to
answer but you just completely cut out
oh boy all right mike congratulations it
sounds like the the connection is
degenerating very very quickly uh so
we're gonna congratulations and i hope
that the answer to how much sleep you're
getting is a lot i hope it's a lot
let's go next to paul garcia from mexico
hi hello
um
i don't know i i guess i i just wanted
your thoughts on uh
a good book like good politics book
that take they teach me like
uh you know background from
conservatives and
you know new ground for progressives to
get into covered that's a great question
you know i i don't read any political
books so i'm like the worst person to
ask because i get so much politics in my
job i read history i read technology i
read do you have a narrative history
book like
friends revolution or something like
that french revolution no i really don't
know french revolution i've not i don't
know you know what i would do for all
these things if you just google
best book about the french revolution i
guarantee you you will find great
recommendations yeah i'd look at a few
cause
they say the french revolution start
kick start the whole revolution thing in
the world
uh i just find it interesting i just
wanted to know uh
uh i
i'm just listening
that that was my only question
uh the chihuahua ah
well that's like 67 degrees that's not
that no 18 is like 66 or something isn't
it yeah yeah something like that that's
not bad that's not bad for almost
november
well
yeah that's that's the city chihuahua
but i live in a uh a town apart okay
it's like
um 16
14 celsius okay got it how where did you
learn english
uh
my whole life i i i have taken english
from preschool
uh elementary
and middle school high school wow well
you speak excellent english my friend
well thank you i i really was fishing
for that all right thanks paul great to
hear from you
yeah you too take care keep the good
work thank you there's paul garcia from
chihuahua in mexico love it
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when i use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say i'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video